[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire j'ai la joie de recevoir
aujourd'hui une écrivains que j'aime
beaucoup y que je n'ai pas vu depuis
longtemps c'est fatou diop bonjour fait
toujours chaud on voudrait des romans
comme le ventre de l'atlantique qui vous
a fait connaître en france et ailleurs
ou impossible de grandir qui vient de
reparaître en poche chez j'ai lu ou un
essai comme marianne porte plainte
aujourd'hui vous sortez de quoi aimer
vivre un recueil de nouvelles chez albin
michel
vous dites dans la dans la première
nouvelle la question souvent n'est pas
tant de quoi vivre mais plutôt de quoi
aimer vivre de quoi aimer vivre encore
d'ailleurs qu'est ce que vous entendez
par là parce que l'assiette plein ou le
portefeuille bien rempli ne suffit pas
pour égayer l'esprit pour donner envie
d'avancer pour donner du courage tout
simplement d'affronter les aléas de
notre vie et je pense que tous les
humains
après avoir trouvé de quoi vivre donc la
subsistance
il cherche à trouver la joie d'exister
et donc de quoi aimer vivre vraiment et
de quoi aimer vivre vraiment j'ai
l'impression que pour la plupart d'entre
nous ça se réduit à aimer tout court en
fait c'est l'amour c'est l'amour c'est
le courage qui nous viennent tout
simplement du regard bienveillant
quelqu'un qui qui vous donne la force
d'espérer quelqu'un qui vous donne la
force de continuer parce que parfois ça
peut être difficile d'affronter le lever
du jour
et quand le lever du jour qu'on a un
sourire comme de vigny et bien là on a
envie d aller parce qu'on se sent à
accompagner tous les personnages des
nouvelles qui se trouvent dans de quoi
aimer vivre ont subi une forme
d'injustice la vie les enferme dans dans
une geôle dont il s'évade avec plus ou
moins de difficultés plus ou moins de
bonheur
vous l'avez fait exprès vous en être
consciente je ne vais pas du tout c'est
exprès parce qu'en plus c'était avant
cette période qui nous enferment
1 oui c'était vraiment avant j'ai
l'impression du coup de porter malheur
d'ailleurs pourquoi je pensais à ses
personnages enfermés
donc on dit par exemple dans la première
nouvelle est enfermé dans son corps
c'est quelqu'un qui est oui c'est
l'injustice de la santé de handicap et
malgré tout c'est lui qui a plus de
courage qui soutient les ce qu'on dit
valide mais faut-il simplement tenir sur
ses deux jambes pour être suffisamment
valides pour la vie andy lui qui est
handicapé il a la force d'aider ceux qui
n'ont absolument rien ceux qui ne sont
pas un handicap comme lui mais c'est lui
qui leur donne la force d'avancer le
courage d'espérer et puis à ceux qui
sont enfermés aussi dans leur caractère
comme dans boxer ou vivre donc ce boxeur
recherche de l'amour et du respect qui
me réussit à inspirer que de la peur
donc il est enfermé dans sa propre
mémoire et il n'a pas réussi à devenir
la doudoune l'adulte qu'il souhaitait et
puis la narratrice a affirmé dans son
jeu les souvenirs de son grand-père et
qui vous en parlera pour le reste du
siècle justement la première nouvelle
c'est le face à face entre on dit ce
personnage d'un handicapé par la polio
et la narratrice qui vous ressemble
comme deux gouttes d'eau et est en fait
il c'est l'un est pile autres à travers
à travers les fenêtres de son
appartement
la narratrice vous en l'occurrence
s'aperçoit tout à coup que c'est tandis
qu'elle croise très souvent dans la rue
ou dans des restaurants ou dans des bars
en fête habite en face de chez elle et
l'esp yonne et j'ai l'impression que ça
c'est quelque chose qui est très
important pour vous il y avait déjà un
autre de vos vos romans
inès où vit la vie qui parlait de ce
voyeurisme entre voisins nous savons
bien ça pourquoi est ce que est ce que
ça vous entre je vous dis dans une autre
vie je n'ai pas croisé hitchcock avec
phone et tous et au cours donc peut-être
que c'est lui qui revient pour un témoin
de l'époque pour m'inspirer cela avec
son film magnifique donc oui c'est
l'être humain le mystère et dans les
maisons on appelle ça des lieux de vie
pourtant là dans votre studio vous êtes
en vie dans ma maison j'ai envie et dans
les supermarchés on est en vie mais
pourquoi les maisons sont sont elles des
lieux de vie et c'était ça qui
interrogeait déjà dans inassouvies nos
vies et ce sont ces villas qui sont
cachés et là la narratrice la déménager
et depuis son installation et en voisin
qui est toujours postés derrière la
fenêtre qui observe donc évidemment
comme une toute jeune fille on va dire
bien élevé avec les canaux var de la
société ont dit mais elle fait sa sainte
nitouche quoi il a peur d'être épié par
à nous et ça ne te rends compte cet
homme-là est bien la délicatesse de cet
homme-là la bienveillance de cet
homme-là septuor de la beauté de cet
homme-là stands il a n'a pas un regard
de vicieux c'est un regard d'amitié
c'est un regard d'attention c'est un
regard qui invite qui ap et donc il
devient l'ami lamic ont soupçonné d'être
un et voyeur il dit mais à n'ont
pas de gros mots à ange-gardien ce
serait mieux
le hasard a bien voulu te placé sous la
surveillance et c'est un rôle qu'il
prend et qui lui tient à coeur parce
qu'il était là et m'a tellement
psychologue que lui aussi il a compris
que ben un canard boiteux identifier
notre canard boiteux mais souvent chez
vos héroïnes fait tous des hommes
on sent qu'elle n'aime pas être vu c'est
le cas de celle ci je sais que par
exemple vous n'aimez pas être vu à la
télévision
à chaque fois il faut vous convaincre
vous l'aimez pas être vu cela vous
embarrassent ça vous embête
mais oui parce que je ne sais pas ce que
je vais raconter alors je suis prêt 1 kg
cris je peux c'est pas que je sais le
faire
mais au moins quand j'écris je je peux
tenter de préciser de 2,6 les encore si
je trouve que je ne suis pas satisfaite
je peux reprendre
et puis à la télévision on pas là des
régions très intelligent que nous et qui
vont se rendre compte de nos bus
donc j'ai toujours temps d'ouvrir la
bouche mais vous mais c'est d'autant
plus affligeant ce qui vous concerne que
parmi les innombrables séquence de ce
soir ou jamais que j'animais autrefois
sur france télévisions celles qui ont
été le plus vu c'est toujours les vôtres
c'était bien et les gens vous guette à
chaque fois dit il ya toujours des
moments de télévision où les gens aiment
vous voir et vous vous écoutez donc ça
devrait vous rassurer
ah non non vous savez quand j'ai
commencé avec mon premier livre
l'éditeur me disais oui tu vas te dis
que tu feras après un ou deux livres tu
vas tu habitués et là je n'ose pas les
contes et jeux
je me vois avancés avec les années et
j'ai toujours le même sentiment avant
chaque émission c'est le même le même
trac avant chaque rencontre
et puis pourtant je dois être maso parce
que je suis conférence sur le reste de
l'année donc et chaque fois avant de
prendre le micro et l'impression que
c'est le dernier jour de ma vie et vous
allaitez progression wifi g oui mais
vous savez quand on quand on quand on
doit donner les cours si académique on
va se cacher derrière le rideau
scientifique pour oser dire de faire les
choses
alors que pour le libre c'est cette
thèse
très sincèrement ma folie à moi et donc
je n'ai pas de pad à voir pour me
protéger
et donc c'est ça la la la fragilité de
ce métier ou wii où je m'enferme pour
vous parler
et ensuite vous vous sentez de ma
tanière pour vous parler alors quand je
m'en sers pour vous écrire les textes
ccem ya presque un côté les enfants qui
se cachent pour dire le gros mot dans le
dos des adultes ya d'ailleurs dans la
première nouvelle
un moment il est dit c'est désagréable
de se savoir observer mais il y a pire
c'est d'être invisible oui oui être
invisible là c'est la hantise c'est une
mort sociale celle non plus
oui c'est non plus un tronc commun
ce n'est même pas remarqué c'est
différent c'est considérer c'est à dire
admis en tant qu'êtres humains présents
et donc quand on ignore votre existence
à ce point là vous finissez par ne plus
exister du tout parce que qu'on le
veuille ou pas même si on n'existe pas
seulement à travers le regard des gens
c'est quand même le regard des gens qui
nous confirme une autre présence si nous
pouvons nous dissocier nous différencier
de de l'identité d'autrui
c'est parce que autrui lui-même nous
renvoie un regard dans lequel nous
pouvons nous reconnaître ou peut-être
nous dissocier de lui pour noter qu'une
différence qui fit wii qui fabrique
notre moi notre petite coco invisible
dans lequel nous enfermant ce que nous
sommes et donc nous ne pouvons pas
existé à l'abri du regard mais le regard
effrayant parce que il peut être un
regard qui juge aussi est d'ailleurs le
personnage dont 10 qui est donc cet
homme handicapé par la polio gravement
handicapé dans sa démarche pas du tout
intellectuellement mais dans cdma il est
invisible au départ et les to sont tout
son effort porte à se rendre visible
justement pour les autres et vous
décrivez très très bien partout les tous
les moyens qu'il emploie pour y parvenir
oui alors il parle comme cela s'il était
le plus grand séducteur du de la région
il est il est coquin et les griesois il
s'est en plaisantant c'est un les joyeux
il taquine tout le monde mais c'est
comme je disais dans le livre il ne
saute pas dans la vie
des gens comme dans une piscine il ya
son petit regard qui sont d'abord qui
prend la température du jour les humeurs
donc il faut lui rende son sourire
d'abord pour qu'ils aient le courage de
s'approcher
donc c'est là toute sa délicatesse même
si les provocateurs et taquin il reste
quelqu'un de très publique et de très
réservé et élégant c'est c'est d'abord
eux c'est avait aussi une histoire de
voyeurisme on l'a dit à travers les
fenêtres entre ses deux appartements et
à partir du moment où elle commence à le
regarder à son tour à travers la fenêtre
vous écrivez quand nous étions le voyeur
il voit son double en où les regards
croisés son miroir réfléchissant et ça
m'a fait penser exactement à ce que est
ce que vladimir poutine dit quand joe
biden l'a accusé d'être un tueur et je
sais pas si je vais bien entendu ce qu'a
dit vladimir poutine il est dit au sun
will be mais il était plus explicite en
fait dans la déclaration n'a retenu que
ça oui 10 et enfin que ce que leur
reproche aux autres c'est souvent ce que
l'on voit dans son propre miroir à mai
exactement parce que moi j'aime bien
justement c'est pour ça que j'aime le
taux dérision parce que quand on
considère que le le regard de andy ça
signale un voyeur et bien à un moment
donné la narratrice donc en fait c'est
moi fois soumet un donc un moment donné
je m'amuse à éteindre la lumière et tout
de suite il était aussi sa lumière
hébergera lui il rallume et puis il me
fait un signe de la main
donc quand je vois un voyeur en lui il
me regarde et je suis sans double parce
que je suis aussi intéressé par sa
personne qu'il l'ait pas la mienne
et puis finalement je dis je vais mettre
des stores et à partir du moment où je
mets les stores bleu devient comme des
enfants et puis on se fait des signes et
là ça devient intentionnel il ya le
regard qu'on n'a pas cherché
accidentellement on repère au remarqué
quelqu'un et puis ensuite il ya eu les
regards que nous avons choisie par
amitié c'est à dire en dise je sais
qu'il est là 7 on repère dans la vie de
tous les jours jeudi le voir à sa
fenêtre savoir comme l'atlantique est
resté dans
dans son lit et que l'everest ne s'est
pas écoulé soutiennent toujours la voûte
du ciel parce que ça devient repères
qu'ils assurent et alors hymne aux siens
je le cherche du regard et tous les
soirs avant de baisser les stores on se
fait des signes comme des enfants donc
oui au s'identifient à on s'identifie
fatou diome vous écrivez toujours sur le
décalage
vous êtes senti souvent décalé dans
votre propre existence
je pense que ce sera un avis comme ça
j'ai toujours été un peu à la marge de
quelque chose
le problème c'est que je ne sais pas où
se trouve le centre et donc je me sens à
la marche de quelque chose parce que il
ya toujours des gens qui définissent le
centre et la périphérie
donc elles ce sont souvent des gens qui
se sentent légitimes ou ou qu'ils savent
qu'ils en ont la puissance qui de crête
de ce qui est le milieu le centre est
donc ce qui doit compter et après
désigne la périphérie donc les revues et
les oublier et tout le tralala donc vous
connaissez ma naissance je les raconte
un long en large et en travers moi je
suis une histoire d'amour de jeunes gens
beaux et heureux de vivre qui ont trouvé
de quoi aimer vivre dans le regard de
l'autre dans leur histoire d'amour et je
pense que je devais être patiente
l'impression d'écrire des poèmes ou je
ne sais pas quoi et j'ai débarqué avant
de programmer et dans ce microcosme
social où je suis né j'étais toujours là
cela donc celle qui n'était pas censé
être légitime et jeu pour que ce moment
il est injuste parce que qui décide de
la légitimité des humains donc voilà je
pense que toutes les vies sont légitimes
et donc dans la vie sociale c'est aussi
pareil dans les situations
vous aurez des gens qui vont qui vont
s'installer et occuper largement leur
place ce que les gens quittent alors
gens comme ça dans le train ou dans le
métro dont qu'ils occupent la place et
ce sans que le droit de le faire et vous
aurez toujours les gens qui se faufile
et qui disent presque
excusez moi d'être là et donc on vous a
souvent rejetés
votre vie vous apprenez même votre corps
il apprend à s'excuser d'être là il
prend une petite place et il ne dérange
pas et andy comme il est handicapé par
certains qui le regardent d'une façon
pas très amènes il leur semble
walt étrangères avec ma couleur chocolat
ça se voit et un certain regard non plus
qu'ils ne m'invite pas mais qui me qui
me repose presque ressemble et andy le
sait donc qu'il m'appelle d'une dame par
exemple en disant tu vois que celle là
elle ne m'aurait pas celui ci tu n'étais
pas là
sous-entendu cette dame le salut
uniquement quand il ya une personne
valide à côté l'huile handicapés et moi
je lui dit mais tu sais un de chacun sa
croix
ben moi non plus je n'ai pas droit à ces
civilités
s'il n'y a pas la présence d'une autre
personne klaus et de on en rigole parce
que chacun de nous pour trouver les
raisons pour lesquelles on le pousse
vers la périphérie et on peut choisir de
les ignorer tout simplement en étant
dans le centre de la burqa nous propose
avec nos amis nos proches tout ça là
l'endroit où vous êtes né c'est l'île de
nias d'or au sénégal un qui est battu
par le vent de l'atlantique
c'est une petite île oui vous dit que
vous étiez regarder mis à part quand
vous étiez enfant parce que vous n'étiez
pas vue comme légitime
mais aujourd'hui si des touristes vont à
niort
c'est parce qu'ils ont lu vos livres
c'est ça qui est drôle en fait ça vous
met encore une fois à part mais vous
êtes cette fois-ci vous êtes au centre
puisque c'est vous et oui et encore une
fois je dérange c'est presque aux coups
de somme et toute ma vie ce sera comme
ça je suis celle qui dérange c'est à
dire comme ça il ya des touches et vous
tendez la pêche vous donner
l'opportunité de le dire il ya des trucs
qui vont filmer jusque dans les
toilettes et les arrête donc la
violation de la vie privée ces mêmes
enfants en france au sénégal aussi mais
ils vont chercher ma famille ou mes
proches et donc certains ne parlent même
pas français mais eux ils font les
débusquer donc il faut qu'ils arrêtent
de transformer ma famille à une
exposition universelle parce que là je
vais
facile donc mais vous voyez là encore je
dérange alors ce sont mes frères mes
soeurs d'europe qui viennent moi quand
je suis là bas sur la vie de leur offrir
des noix de coco et des grillades de
poisson par contre quand je me suis là
bas ça m'attriste un peu qu'ils
dérangent des gens qui sont parfois très
timide et réservé dans les îles le
célèbre sont des gens très pudique il ya
il ya un possible de grandir que j'ai là
qui vient de ressortir un poche qui est
un livre que j'ai beaucoup de vous parce
que c'est c'est vous encore une fois ça
peut pas être quelqu'un d'autre que vous
cette héroïne c'est votre double et où
son drame c'est que une de ses amies l'a
invitée à dîner chez elle et je n'ai pas
aller chez les autres elle n'aime
tellement pas aller chez les autres que
ça en fait un roman un gros roman oui
lorsque son amie l'a invitée à dîner et
je trouve ça nous ressemble énormément
et cette idée de ne pas aimer aller chez
les autres mais au fond que je crois que
ça dissimule sais que vous n'aimez pas
qu'on vient de chez vous non chez moi
j'aime bien faire à manger que les gens
viennent chez moi parce que je ne leur
ferait pas de mal donc je sais qu'il
peut revenir j'ai pas peur c'est moi a
laissé des gens que je ne connais pas
bien par exemple
donc quand je rentre dans une maison et
que je n'ai pas les clés je ne sais pas
ce que vous réitère de nous donner les
clefs de votre maison
parce que quand j'étais petit parfois
j'ai travaillé chez des gens et qu'ils
veulent on tape les femmes la porte et
je vois pas pourquoi mon cuir et donc
c'est resté dans ma tête de pin savez
j'ai travaillé dans le vide et j'avais
12 ans et demi et depuis 7 ans l'âge et
mais jamais cessé de travailler
oui mais vraiment arrivé de travailler
chez des gens et quand ils voulaient me
tabasser est fermé et je ne sais pas par
où partie ya ça mais il ya aussi même
dans la famille certains membres de ma
famille il est arrivé donc je parle de
le dire quand je vous raconte la
naissance que je vous raconte vous
pouvez imaginer la place près sierre
conservez donc cette fille là au dessus
comme s'il fallait pour rectifier le sol
le problème c'est que cette faute là
mais elle a deux jambes et deux auraient
et demain etc
elle a une bouche donc cette faute sur
pattes de la corriger
donc leur maison pour moi c'est une
geôle c'est une prison possible et quand
je ne connais pas bien les gens il faut
qu'il le comprenne je sais à quel point
ils sont adorables comptez-vous le
mérite est chez eux mais avec quand je
rencontre une nouvelle personne ma
première percée quand est ce qui va me
dire que j'ai à la maison et je prie
pour que ça n'arrive pas ou pour que ça
arrive le plus tard possible
donc j'adore aller au restaurant invité
au restaurant rencontrer les gens haut
placés
allez pour des balades d'un dans le
libre jeudi invitée mois pour une balade
au bord de mer
mes parents et moi vos intérieurs je me
touche dans le mien mais de 2,2 de se
sentir décalé vous semble en avoir
souffert vous auriez pu en faire un un
avantage vous dites d'ailleurs dans une
des nouvelles de ce nouveau recueil que
même dans la jungle les les animaux aux
l'originalité c'est même ainsi qu'il
survive
ah oui au changement de leur
environnement oui parce que de toute
façon alors c'est ça une marginalité
lorsqu'elle est assumée revendiquée et
bien on peut la mettre en valeur et en
plus elle devient carrément une identité
finalement une identité c'est un
habitant taillé à sa mesure
et alors que les gens ils vous rejette
c'est mon grand père qui m'a appelé ça
pour certains membres de la famille des
ongles par exemple qui m'ont jeté hors
de leur maison mais comme une chienne
c'est vraiment arrivé à dakar
un nom qui vous suit la rue à 20h quoi
et alors je me sens mais oui si j'étais
chez mon père et si c'était ça ma mère
donc la malle gros merde tu seras jamais
c'est ton père et ta mère c'est comme ça
donc il faut vivre la vie et à lormont
groupama change manif est il me dit tu
sais les gens vous le t'exprimes exclure
j'ai dit oui
ils sont obligés de délimiter
c'est quoi ne vient pas dans ma maison
ou longchamp ou ensemble ou ma pirogue
mon village où voilà c'est quelque chose
qui est toujours délimité et je fais oui
oui mais ne sois pas triste
ça vous dit que le reste du monde
mais pour toi et donc du coup il vous
apprend presque à devenir le mégalo à
l'autre la limite est maintenant dans sa
petite maison là où on peut même pas
faire un terrain de football et à
l'immensité de ce monde entier qui
m'attend et tout ça je suis libre d'y
aller donc c'est simple quand on vous
interdit de choses apprenez à conquérir
votre propre route quand on vous
interdit aux bateaux prenez votre
modeste balkh et tracer votre siège
cette liberté là je trouve que les plus
poétiques que le simple fait de rallier
alger n'hésitez pas je peux pas j'étais
passé maman est alors moi je me fais
rire mes grands parents sont les
meilleurs parents du monde
mon grand-père et vallée d'ousse père et
ma grand-mère et le valais 25 couverts
comment vous avez trouvé strasbourg
quand vous êtes à vue parce que vous
vivez toujours à strasbourg
vous êtes passé oui sénégal à strasbourg
strasbourg est omniprésente dans vos
livres
comment l'avez vous trouvée au premier
abord tous les packs tous les français
ne connaissent pas strasbourg
moi j'étais émerveillé la première fois
quand il a traversé je traversé la ville
donc arriver simplement et traverser la
vie larchitecture déjà donc en plus à
une vraie différence d'architecturé
parce qu'il ya les quartiers des années
1900 ou même du xviiie siècle les
anciennes maisons à colombages tout ça
et puis vous avez les constructions
modernes et surtout cerise sur le gâteau
vous avez quand même cette cathédrale
millénaire qu'on admire les gens
viennent du monde entier et devant
l'oeuvre des hommes je les dis
d'ailleurs je crois dans inassouvies nos
vies voir ce que les humains sont
capables de produire quand ils ont la
foi et derrière là je ne parle même pas
de la foi religieuse je parle de la foi
de quelques choses les plus humains elle
peut être religieuse elle peut être
autre chose mais d'avoir la foi en
quelque chose de vrai pour les les gens
sont capables de produire des merveilles
et donc quand il écrit
c'est comme si strasbourg elle et elle
m'accompagne
elle me elle me fait des dédicaces en
fait strasbourg 5 8 dames et ex pour
dire qu'il était dans une super belle
ville pour écrire ce livre là donc
et parce que ces présents dans ma tête
dans mon histoire d'envoi c'est aussi la
ville du monde là où j'ai le plus
pleurer de toute ma vie
et donc c'est aussi la ville de
l'humilité c'est aussi la ville de huy
de l'humilité de la modestie j'étais
femme de ménage ici maintenant je me
prends pour le romancier dans la même
ville donc tout ça dans la même ville
donc finalement la vie humaine c'est
tellement rapide c'est tellement fou
grèce c'est rien du tout et ça peut
changer du jour au lendemain et moi
cette chose là elle me bouleverse
je ne crie pas victoire j'ai
l'impression de marcher sur le chemin où
je découvre encore strasbourg pouvais me
filer des bases et puis m'émerveiller et
puis me câliner
regardez cette analyse à sion mon ami
andy mais j'ai rencontré aux sidéens et
ceux qui sont pour moi comme de grandes
soeurs ou de grand frère et si aussi
strasbourg
et c'est aussi là où mon ex m'a largué
j'ai pleuré comme si j'allais mourir et
c'est pas vrai on meurt pas du tout
quand on voulait de luffy souriez vous
survivez à ça et puis vous découvrez une
autre partie de vous même
voilà tant pis pour ceux qui sont partis
strasbourg est resté fidèle
moi aussi on fait une pause fait audio
mais on vous retrouve avec bonheur juste
après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec fatou diop qui
publie chez albin michel de quoi aimer
vivre un recueil de nouvelles et son
roman impossible de grandir lui vient
d'être réédité en poche chez j'ai lu ou
plutôt il sort en poche chez j'ai lu la
première fois avant d'arriver à
strasbourg je crois que vous êtes arrêté
à près de saint malo sur la tombe de
châteaubriand alors est ce que c'est
vrai ce que c'est une légende on va
l'avoir derrière moi la tombe de
chateaubriand elle est sur une île elle
aussi enfin plutôt sur un îlot l'îlot du
grand baie voilà il est là il est face à
la mer patricia delage et lyon qui vous
attirait ou est-ce que c'était la mer
gelée les deux évidemment mais mais
c'était mon premier et mes premières
vacances d'été en france
j'étais donc à saint malo à ploërmel
parce que j'ai ma famille bretonne là
bas aussi
et vous voyez c'est ce que je disais les
gens qui nous accueillent qui nous aime
qui nous font découvrir et donc comme
apatride docteur je dirais pas seulement
parce qu'elle est encore et mais voilà
c'est une élégante aux dames qui
n'aimerait pas cool biz mise c'est une
dame dans mon coeur in tata à moi qui
m'a amené là bas qui m'avez visité et
qui récite et aussi des textes et des
extraits de textes de 7 ans brillant
mais aussi des poèmes et com - la
morosité la poésie et l'âge ce parti
parce que à ce que j'avais lu mais alors
que j'étais gamine et que je ne pouvais
même pas comprendre
et alors en grandissant en relisant les
mémoires d'outre-tombe
on se rend compte qu'on n'a pas fini
d'apprendre la langue française et vous
savez ces métaphores je sais comment
jamais d'étonner que parfois certains me
le reproche
mais à côté de châteaubriant je ne suis
que notts county quoi lui il mettait la
tartine la marmelade et puis mettez du
golan dessus parce que la langue
française est copieuse et qu'il a
savourée et ben voila moi j'aime ses
auteurs la qui ont des textes roboratif
et très construit et étoffé et puis
comment on va dire bourreau déconcertés
ou je ne sais pas mais tous ces maux
la finesse de la langue et lui c'est ça
et alors autre chose mémoire d'autres
tomoka même pour le trouver ce titre là
c'est d'une beauté est alors lui il est
là et a une fille qui viennent du nil au
bout du mois de labeur sénégal
et ça tombe là elle surplombe
l'atlantique donc ses mémoires au dessus
de l'atlantique comme fait lui il
surplombe la mer quoi donc même si c'est
la moche et prom la mer dans de quoi
aimer vivre il ya une nouvelle où vous
faites parler là la petite robe noire
d'edith piaf et ça m'a fait penser à
hacker talent à un nouveau roman où ce
sont les meubles et les objets d'une
défunte qui redoutent d'être séparée
d'être éparpillés il voudrait rester
ensemble et est ce que vous croyez que
les objets ont une âme et aimer même
mieux qu'une âme de la conversation à
alphonse de lamartine pose la question
objets inanimés avez-vous donc une âme
aimé mois qui viennent d'une culture
d'origine vraiment ministre qui était là
c'était ma manière de répondre oui mais
oui par le livre lui-même en tant que
tel c'est à dire que on découvre toute
l'histoire du personnage de memoria
justement là mémorial est il on découvre
toute l'histoire de mes moyens à travers
le discours direct de ces objets qui ont
hérité de tous les défauts des humains
se chamaillent ils se contredisent unis
valises
chacun est plus proche du saignant
l'espagne donc chacun de ces objets ne
revendique plus de proximité avec un
mémorial et c'était une manière aussi de
briser le mur halte relais roman et le
théâtre
donc le discours direct pour construire
toute la trame romanesque de ce livre
avec l'anthropomorphisme à sion ça m'a
beaucoup amusé mais la route de pierre
aurait pu trouver sa place là dedans
elle aussi elle aurait pu faire un roman
et raconter toutes les amours de serre
dans ce géant qui va des chaussées la
petite comment les petits pieds de
pierre et cette robe là on l'expérience
et c'est troublant n'a plus appropriée
est longue la porte ou une mémoire ces
troubles être
c'est toute une époque et on l'admiré
depuis tous les pays du monde entier qui
connaissent la langue française admis
lui a fait alors et on parle de ses
preuves en dix ans la petite robe ces
qualificatifs que les humains utilisent
parfois la petite robe alors que quand
ils parlent de pillage et de la grande
donc la grande et depuis apple nous a
quittés comment la grande et depuis
apporté le portait une petite robe et
donc voilà ça sa révolte et c'est aussi
la nostalgique qui fait parler c'est rob
et oui elle voudrait qu'on lui donne un
peu plus de considération au lieu de la
très emballé d'une salle d'exposition à
l'autre mais peut-être qu'elle exagère
son importance cette petite robe
parce que on parle effectivement vous
avez réseau toujours de la petite robe
de piaf comme s'il n'en avait eu qu'une
mais regarde bien les photos de pierre
fallait toujours en noir c'est toujours
une robe et mais c'est jamais la mairie
s'est jouée écoute différente des
décolletés différents selon les époques
c'est pas la même mode etc vous fouillez
les manches aussi les manchots s'ils
changent mais on a toujours su faire
c'est symbolique c'est toujours la
petite robe noire les dames d'art de
toujours au fond de la valise
donc quand il une soirée les surprend
elle va sortir la petite robe donc je
pense que beaucoup de femmes en tout cas
ont toujours leurs petites robes noires
au fond de la valise au cas où est alors
l élève et l'élégance donc d'être à la
mode tout le temps et donc la petite
rebelle dix ans par pierre et s'adapter
à la mode ce sont les modes qui la
trouvaient toujours à la page
et cette petite robe pour moi elle parle
au nom de toutes les robes que nous
aimons finalement et on parle toujours
de la dame et on ne parle pas de ses
habits fétiche donc hors date de moi
avec mon grimaud donc et je suis sûr que
si je m'endormais demain aussi je
prenais des réponses définitives
on va donner un chiffre au move voter il
m'est très cher vous le mettez très
souvent ou son équivalent je ne sais pas
quand vous avez une émission de
télévision et je ne sais pas d'ailleurs
vous poser la question ce que je me suis
peut-être que ça renferme des secrets
mais c'est évident que c'est pousser
pour vous l'équivalent de la petite robe
noire
oui moi j'ai des les échanges
ici il y en a des quantités et en plus
c'est contagieux donc ma grand mère je
pense que les ventes à nu dans les
années de sa vie elle avait connu que
des échecs morts partout à cause de moi
et beaucoup de gens que je connais c'est
pareil parce qu'en plus je suis clinique
j'adore les amours comme ça je les vois
quelqu'un comme moi je les porte
ça me fait plaisir mais je la vois pas
alors que les chefs mort quand quelqu'un
d'autre mes soeurs mes amis ou ma grand
mère car les personnes autour de moi les
portes je peux les voir c'est donc ça me
fait encore plus plaisir quand quelqu'un
d'autre la porte et où il ya le livre
mauve qui explique tous en rapport avec
la couleur mauve donc c'est le bleu et
le rouge le bleu c'est l'horizon c'est
l'espoir
le rouge c'est la dépression hélas je
lis souvent traversé et si je mélange
les deux parce que je ne veux pas perdre
espoir si je mélange les deux jets le
mot mais le bleu c'est aussi l'europe le
froid bleu européen et la rouge chaleur
africaine
c'est aussi le rouge les pompiers ils
ont leur flair de détresse est toujours
rouge mais vous allez voir la mer là moi
qui viens du nil l'horizon est toujours
bleu surtout pour celui qui au strass et
son sillage vous mélangez le rouge et le
bleu vous avez d'humour et alors autre
chose que j'aime c'est que le move c'est
une couleur d'addition health annulerait
si chacune des deux couleurs se
mettaient à devenir secteur voilà si
lors je ne supporte pas le bleu est bien
y aura pas de mots et si le bleu ne
supporte pas le rouge il y aura pas de
mot ça correspond exactement à ce que
j'ai dans la tête vous enlever ma
culture africaine il ya une demi fatto
vous enlever ma culture française il ya
une demi fatto donc pour m'avoir
complètement enfin presque on va dire il
faut additionner les deux et donc que
j'aime bien cette addition là et je
trouve qu'en mathématiques l'addition
m'intéresse beaucoup plus que la
soustraction étudiants celle-ci on l'on
soustrait le
on peut soustraire le virus un duc au
vide de tout ça je suis d'accord pour
celui là mais en général les autres
soustractions ça peut mal vous faites
souvent allusion aux bonnes manières
c'est très important pour vous je crois
que vous êtes quelqu'un d'extrêmement
civilisé au fond mais j'ai élevé par une
famille à hawaï avant l'âge
j'avais mes copines de 80 90 vent donc
non mais c'est vrai quoi quand j'étais
quand j'étais à l'école primaire
parfois mes compagnes de conversation
c'était les dalles de 70 75 ans
et quand j'étais au lycée quand je
revenais en vacances mais j'avais mais
délicieuse compagne de discussion pour
prendre le thé l'après midi avec les
beignets 2002 ma grand-mère ces deux
mamies de 85 cents donc du coup à force
de les voir m'apprend des choses et
maintenant dire des choses il ya des
choses qu'on va grand-mère m'apprenez on
va dire que c'est m
je ne sais pas comment on peut dire à
l'époque quand j'étais petit je trouvais
que l' exagérer on peut et moi je me
suis reprend aujourd'hui à respecter
scrupuleusement ces choses là et parfois
je me trouve dans un véhicule
donc alors et c'est des choses qui vont
par exemple servir le vernis par exemple
elle dit il faut que ce soit impeccable
ou qu on n est pas du tout c'est une
amie quand il pourrait y avoir une
petite miette c'est pas grave pourquoi
mais bon elle sait où c'est nickel ou la
lettre et amour oui les maisons par
exemple on doit inviter des gens il faut
que ce soit imputable
et quand on le droit de voyager il faut
bien nettoyer la maison avant de partir
vous savez pourquoi
parce que si jamais aux mains d'un cours
de route et les gens viennent chez nous
il faut penser qu'on vivait comme sion
et donc du coup moi je dois passer je
pense ma nuit à nettoyer avant de partir
excédés des petites choses
croustillantes comme ça avec le grand
père et la grand mère et le grand père
par contre lui je ne sais pas comment le
requalifier en cette époque où je pense
qu'il était avant de garder celui mais
élevé comme un petit garçon d'ailleurs
il m'appelait mon petit matelot vous
décrivez votre grand père dans une des
nouvelles et vous dites qu'en fait c'est
le vieil homme et la mer d'hemingway
grand-père cela petit bard gelé oui
quand je lis limoux et à l'époque
j'étais au collège je voulais quitter
mon village et j'étais au collège
donc j'étais tout jeune et j'avais pas
quelqu'un pour m'expliquer parce que
évidemment quand on est au collège ce
livre là on ne peut pas le comprendre
complètement
oui on capte des choses mais quand même
je pense qu'on n'est pas assez mûr pour
l'entrée dans la profondeur de l'analyse
de diminuer donc je les lui au collège
et j'étais juste content de savoir payer
que cet empêcheur mon grand père aussi
et puis diego et la petit matelot et mon
grand père aussi
donc si le petit matelot de yobe scène
d'assaut et ben je suis le petit matelot
de mon grand père est alors ça c'était
le premier plaisir et quand j'ai grandi
que j'étais au lycée j'ai relu en cours
et chaque fois que je les ai j'étais
plus sensibles aux textes parce que du
coup je voyais des choses par rapport à
mon grand père que je ne prenais
peut-être pas comme avant parce que je
n'étais peut-être pas assez assez futé
ou assez mûr pour les voir et donc ce
livre est devenu comme un talisman et
j'ai une reconnaissance pour émigrer
mais parce qu'il m'a gardé un souvenir
du maroc était mon grand père de ce
combattant pour la vie de cet homme fier
digne ils luttent et et jeudi que lui
c'est no ce sont nos nuits tranquilles
qu'il sortait de l'eau quoi elle c'était
la subsistance de quoi vivre et grâce à
lui on avait de quoi vivre et avec son
sourire
on avait la sécurité et de quoi aimer
vivre et c'était ça le premier de mes
grands hommes c'est mon grand père il ya
une nouvelle toujours dans de quoi aimer
vivre sur une réfugiée qui a traversé la
méditerranée pour échapper
un pays en guerre les réfugiés les les
bonnes manières resto sur les bonnes
manières les bonnes manières voudrait
qu'on les accueille
elle et ses semblables oui et eyal à
l'article l 622 il ajoutant 11e command
commandement
alors jeunes accueillera pointons
prochain ou bien la loi vous mettez en
5000 euros damende pardi qu'est ce qui
vous a pris d'être quelqu'un de bien
vous serez punis parce que vous êtes
certain de bien c'est quand même
paradoxal dans la patrie de marivaux il
faudrait le réveiller pour qu'il en
fasse une pièce de théâtre ce serait
fantastique sépare l'île de la raison ce
serait ligne de la déraison
parce qu'avant on pu laisser les gens
pour non à cause de la non assistance à
personne en danger et donc maintenant la
nouvelle vertu si on applique vraiment
l'article l622 c'est l'indifférence qui
deviendrait la nouvelle vertu et moi
c'est pas la france que je connais c'est
pas la france qui m'a appris c'est pas
la france que j'aime et donc j'ai osé le
dire dans cette nouvelle là parce que
monsieur s'imbriquent et roux pour moi
c'est un héros c'est celui qui a osé se
dresser et dire moi je ferai ce que ma
conscience modique et il l'a fait à ses
risques et périls et moi c'était ma
manière de lui faire ma révérence et
c'était aussi ma manière de montrer
c'est l'espoir de ces gens là qui
viennent d'ailleurs
chassés par la guerre et qui espère
retrouver un peu de dignité humaine
le problème c'est que quand on donne
langil à quelqu'un mais à l'usure on ne
lui donne pas la dignité on ajoute à son
désespoir et donc c'est pour ça que je
voulais dire dans ce texte ouest cbt
rousset ce berger de la vallée de la
roya qui a qui a mais qui a d'ailleurs
gagné à la fin du tribunal
qu'est ce qu'il a il a obtenu
que la fraternité serait consacrée par
le conseil constitutionnel il a gagné
contre l'état français
effectivement on lui reprochait d'avoir
non pas hébergé mais qu'on voyait
rennais des étrangers sans papiers de
leur avoir fait passer la frontière
entre la france et l'italie
et il a gagné entre autres parce que il
n'y a pas de frontière entre la france
et l'italie aujourd'hui l'état demande
de respecter cette frontière alors
qu'elle n'existe plus puisqu'on est à
l'espace schengen et donc il a il a
gagné au lait pour vous les bons ou
gagner à la fin quand même ah oui et
puis vous avez entendu ce qu'il a dit à
la sortie il a dit au moins
l'hospitalité
enfin la solidarité ne sera pas un délit
et je trouve la formule très jolie la
solidarité ne sera pas un délai ne sera
jamais un délit et il l'a prouvé il
s'est battu comme quoi quand on se bat
pour les belles valeurs pour les juste
valeur et ben on est du bon côté de
l'histoire et il est donc j'imagine que
pendant la guerre il ya des gens qui ont
osé être du bon côté du juste combat et
ils ont été honorés pour cela et donc
j'espère que ce pays là un jour va
honorer ses briques héros comme un de
ses dignes fils une de ces consciences
vives en vivant ce jeudi que ces
machines et non pas la sorbonne
mais là bas dans la vallée de la roya
les vaches ont toujours vu les autres
debout et les moniales ne laisse pas
qu'il colle dans une crevasse
parce que ils ont eu l'habitude
d'accueillir des gens pendant la guerre
pendant le nazisme ils ont appris des
gens qui fuiaient le nazisme des juifs
ils ont appris aussi des italiens qui
fuyaient le fascisme est alors tout ça
je les ai appris dans les livres
d'histoire et j'imagine que tous les
étrangers qu'ils ont appuyé là bas s'ils
sont curieux ils vont interroger cette
histoire et eelv on l'admiré et c'est
aussi ça la grandeur d'un pays c'est
aussi ça qui fait que les gens admire et
respecte la france cdc drik héroux plus
cédric héroux plus des gens j'ai plus
d'autres encore et d'autres voilà ils se
sont tous ces gens là qui ont gardé un
jour la nuque raide qui font qu'on garde
encore la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité en ligne de mire mais fatou
diop est ce que ça ne nous dit pas aussi
nîmes
de la littérature ou du cinéma si on
prend le cinéma depuis qu'il existe
il n'a raconté que des histoires de
héros qui ressemble à cédric héros c'est
à dire des gens qui vont aider celui qui
est le plus faible ils vont aider le
persécuter vont les bergers ils vont lui
permettre de s'enfuir
c'est tous les héros de cinéma lé héros
de romans sont comme ça et et pourtant à
la fin on vote des lois pour que nous ne
soyons pas et la majorité des français
sont tout à fait d'accord avec cette loi
ces lois pas celle là en particulier
mais mais avec les lois qui veut que un
moment d'un des frontières et que on
peut pas comme l'avait dit michel rocard
accueillir toute la misère du monde et
donc voilà on ferme nos frontières et
pourtant le cinéma et la littérature et
tous les héros que nous avons aimés nous
disent le contraire
oui parce que alors qui a dit ça
d'ailleurs la l'éthique c'est plus
compliqué le jour où on devra
l'appliquer à soi-même
donc c'est sans doute plus facile d'en
parler et d'honorer quelques héros pour
ce qu'ils ont osé faire mais c'est plus
difficile de l'appliquer
cédric et oui il c'est le prix qu'il a
payé combien de nuits
comment ça lui a gâché son sommeil ça la
dérange et sa vie pendant un certain
temps il a dû perdre beaucoup de temps
pour se battre pour ces valeurs là donc
qu'être des valeurs ça coûte quelque
chose et c'est pas ce n'est ce ne sont
pas 1
tout le monde n'est pas prêt à payer ce
prix là et c'est seulement ça je pose
qui isole et mais sur une estrade celui
qui a osé défendre ces valeurs là et je
pense par exemple à des gens et par
exemple aujourd'hui la voix de daniel
balavoine par exemple me manque
j'aimerais tellement l'entendre en cette
période donc déjà avec les migrants mais
aussi avec le yémen avec avec la
birmanie avec le convient de tout ce qui
se passe maintenant en tournée salvayre
pourquoi pourquoi nier sa fougue
j'aimerais l'entendre aujourd'hui par
les lois parce que ce sont des gens
comme ça qui osent et j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour ça méfiez-vous peuvent
être qu'il aurait changé à l'époque les
années
80 c'était la grande mode tout le monde
était frère c'était we are the world we
are the people l'humanitaire était roi
aujourd'hui c'est complètement passée de
mode
aujourd'hui c'est l'identité qui prime
c'est pas l'humanité ah non aujourd'hui
on entend palais de l'identité malade
c'est différent l'identité elle est
éclectique
les composites d'ailleurs on n'a qu'à
regarder la la la définition que
l'unesco donne à la culture c'est
l'ensemble des acquis donc si la culture
c'est l'ensemble des acquis je suis
désolé l'identité ce n'est comme il faut
avec un peu de crème ou moins de crem
plus sucré ou pas du tout donc peut-être
seulement la pauvreté de celui qui a
cette culture elle peut être moins de
grâce plus onctueuse ou ou plus fade
mais il se trouve que c'est un big three
alors les gens qui sont là pour passer
leur vie à se parer tout ça c'est
franchement quand ils n'ont pas d'idéal
peut-être dans l'ordre et quelque chose
de plus important parce que avec
qu'attend justifier son identité c'est
qu'on ne sait pas quoi en faire
alors que quand on sait quoi en faire
pour la faire grandir on n'a pas le
temps d'observer le minimum de ce côté
on a envie de l'agrandir je prends comme
un grand mère vous devez expliquer
pourquoi mais justement la dernière
nouvelle de votre recueil et sur ce
sujet et vous dites que la littérature
n'a pas de frontières néanmoins les
écrivains ont une origine
je dirais pas l'identité mais une
origine
il n'y a pas plus français que proust et
céline il n'y a pas plus américain
qu'hemingway d'une certaine manière on
n'écrit pas de nulle part
oui et samuel beckett a bien écrit aussi
en français et donc et puis la patate
douce elle a aussi une régime
mais quand on la déguste elle n'a pas eu
vent de sable c'est parce qu'on est à
ajouter quelque chose et c'est pareil
pour les humains donc pour moi comme je
le dis dans la nouvelle halle il ne
convainc pas et pour ses origines c'est
à dire en raison de ses origines et à
travers ses origines si on lit en auto
uniquement pour cela pour moi
on devine son humanité en deux c'est à
dire qu'on apprécie pour sa part
d'appartenance donc de rattachement de
socle et qu'on ne vaut pas la pression
pour sa part d'élan et d'ouverture et de
personnalité propre
parce que même si on appartient à un
groupe
eh ben on n'est pas monolithique que
c'est pas un groupe homogène
monolithique chacun dans ce groupe-là a
son identité propre et donc je pense que
l'écrivain déjà même si les prix dans sa
langue maternelle
il n'utilise pas sa langue maternelle il
utilise ce qu'il a fait dans sa langue
maternelle
donc quand j'écris en français j'utilise
le français mais je n'utilise pas le
français de rabelais ou de fénelon ou de
jersey qui d'autre j'utilise le français
d'après va savoir à moi d'après tous les
auteurs que j'ai pu admirer qui m'ont
éduquée et pour leurs valeurs et pour
leur style
il ya quand même l'immense
l'inaccessible you soon as donc
s'engourdit prochaine des ronds de jambe
ou mais yourcenar sait quelque chose
donc j'ai étudié des deux mais quand
j'écris je ne crie ni comme celui mis à
jour cela parce que leur immense
personnalité là elle n'annule pas la
mienne
donc du coup même si elle est toute
petite j'ai la force de dents à ma
manière
donc chacun 6l la langue fait un bijou
mais chacun doit adopter son alliance à
sa propre main à son propre loi et c'est
ça pour moi la langue donc je n'ai aucun
complexe par exemple d'utiliser la
langue française
l'élan pour moi ne sont pas en
compétition ni un combat ni à rivaliser
donc pour ma l'écrivain sait comment
masson
j'utilise les pierres dont je dispose
pour construire la bâtisse est au fond
la littérature n'a pas de frontières
c'est l'idée qu'elle doit être comprise
elle peut être comprise absolument
partout quels que soient les références
de chacun et au fond c'est ce qu'on voit
c'est ça la grande littérature c'est ce
qui reste beau et vrai partout et de
toutes les époques
tout ce que nous aurions hannibal
jacques au 19e siècle est toujours vrai
aujourd'hui alors qu'il ya des romans il
ya dix ans on n'y croyait pas il ya dix
ans on n'y croit toujours pas
aujourd'hui ce qui fait la ligue grande
littérature balzac tolstoï dostoïevski
tous ces souris beau et vrai partout où
que ce soit où que soit l'endroit où on
est mis à bas simon prenait john
steinbeck avec les raisins de la colère
donc m'étais juste les informations à 20
ans pour voir comment les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils disent de leur
condition donc regarder les usines qui
ferment ou alors des gens qui n'ont pas
travaillé pendant un certain temps
c'est à dire l'inquiétude du prolétaire
deux là s'entendent il ya mille ans
quand on regarde ce qu'ils sont dans le
même c'est pas le même contexte
mais la même nécessité humaine ces
gens-là d'hier ont pratiquement les
mêmes choses donc ça veut dire que les
auteurs qui ont un regard sur l'humain
mais d'abord l'humain
qu'importe où il est né et où qu'est ce
qu'il fait ou mais l'être humain le
texte là pour moi y passe les frontières
donc c'est un texte qui va abattre les
murs pourquoi parce que d'autres humains
vont s'identifier à partir du moment où
d'autres d'autre que l'auteur pour se
reconnaître dans le texte est bien lire
le texte uniquement pour la l'origine de
l'auteur devient quelque chose de ne
faut pas justifié et pas justifiable je
comprends bien on puisse être intéressé
par le sénégal à moléson
il faut juste que les gens qui cherchent
le sénégal à me disant qu'ils
comprennent que je ne travaille pas au
ministère de tout résoudre
donc voila moi je fabrique des textes le
sénégal que je raconte ce monde se
régale à moi à ma façon de voir ce
sénégal l'a donc peut-être quelqu'un
doute pour raconter la même époque la
même période et ne pas connaître du tout
les choses dont je parle
mais quand j'en parle c'est pas pour
vous raconter du champion
le pouvoir contre ce qui m'a révolté là
dedans pour l'instrument et se révolte
ça aurait était la même quel que soit
l'être humain en question merci fatou
diop d'avoir passé toute cette émission
avec nous
le de quoi aimer vivre c'est le titre de
votre nouveau recueil de nouvelles qui
vient de paraître chez albin michel
et puis impossible de grandir c'est un
roman plus antérieure et qui vient de
reparaître en poche chez j'ai lu
merci encore merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]